OF ROOKIES, NATE COYOTES IN THET
1:13 HAVE TAKEN A SHOT, JUST SIG
THERE, WAITING.. ACROSS, TO
THE MIDDLE A CHANCE.
EMPLOYED THERE AGAIN AND A STOP,
IT'S UNDERNEATH IN THE C SHOT.
ENDS UP IN THE CORNER.
MEANWHILE, MAYO I
BLOCKER, I BELIEVE AND DO THE
TOP CORNER ON VEJMELKA, O KESSEL
IS IN.
A LOT OF
THE UPPER PART OF THE CAGE.
SHOOTS,NEN ALL OVER HIM.
KESSEL TO THENET.
>> VEJMELK PUCK?
IS IT IN HIS GLOVE? BAHL.
I BELIEVE THAT MIGHT BE HIS, YOG
THE FENDERS WITH YOU.
SCORES.
NICK SCHMAART.
YOU LOOK AT DAWS, HE'S STILL
LOLO LAST 12
GAMES.
>> AND THE D D ALONE,
VEJMELKA CAN'T GET BACK BETWEEN
THE PIPES IN TIME, AND SCORE AGS
TONIGHT.
SCORE.
THAT'S SHARANGOVICH AND IT'S BY
TWO WATER BOTTLE.
THE ZONE.
TRIED TO POKE IT ON VEJMELKA,AMA
CHANCE, GALCHENYUK, AND THAT'S
DENIED BY DAWS.
>> LATE
LUCKY OFF THE SKATE OF
GALCHENYUK RIGHT BACK.
BOQVIST TO ZACHA, AND A STOP
ONE-TIMER, TOUGH SHOT TO GET